when you were starting out rink time as
everyone knows uh who's played hockey or
had a kid who's played hockey rink time
or ice time is very expensive
your dad was had a modest income
he was frugal so he made you a rink
in the backyard is that right yeah and
everybody thinks he made it
to uh make me a professional hockey
player but that wasn't true i used to go
to ponds like everyone else and ski for
hours and hours
and my dad said you know what we're
going to do here is i'm
freezing going to the rinks with my son
so i'm going to build a rink in the
backyard and i can watch in the kitchen
where it's worn so every everybody says
how did your dad make that rink
he used to go and he'd buy these
sprinklers and then
have the sprinkler going back and forth
right and uh he
used to say to my mother phyllis will
you go down to the store and buy a
sprinkler
and my mom would say it's december
walter they're going to think i'm nuts
you go buy it
i know they made you your own rank and
then he would just i love it he would
sit
stand in the kitchen nice and warm and
toasty but you were out there for hours
yeah and just occasionally look out the
window you know well one time i was out
there because i used to go there
all the time i loved it was my passion
and i was about five years old
and my dad tells the story he got into
bed and my mother said
is wayne in bed he goes oh my god i left
him in the backyard